travail abnégation courage à l'image de
ces débats et de matisse dossou yovo au
shoot à l'échauffement les joueurs de
l'as des as blot a concentré ne cesse de
répéter leurs gammes
ok maintenant la même chose
tic ander sur le deuxième du sceptre du
step et là je veux on donne
automatiquement le ballon en 5è là où il
ya de joueurs le mec qui prend ligne de
fond comme l'a fait l'animateur des
séances d'entraînement très intensive
parfois dur même mené par le coach de
toujours dit qu'en dehors
l'objectif est très clair compenser
l'absence de rythme du manque de
compétition en raison de la crise fin
janvier le tiers du championnat et tout
juste atteint tout en gardant un oeil du
site sur la montée l'absence de public
c'est compliqué mais je pense que si on
avait un certain avec nous dans la
saison ce serait plus facile
tandis que là non seulement ya pas
publics mais en plus ça on a des grands
moments de police en or on joue pas
pendant des deux semaines trois semaines
un mois on n'a pas vraiment de
visibilité sur la suite du championnat
alors je pense que le plus compliqué
c'est ça c'est de se projeter arrivée
n'est là pour le coach peu importe les
obstacles
l'exigence reste le maître mot aucun
joueur n'a de statut protégé dans cette
équipe c'est vrai qu'on a des joueurs
importants notamment à la version comme
charlene johnson était mbp deux fois du
championnat mais je veux que tout le
monde soit en piqué même les jeunes qui
joue que cinq six minutes devait
impliquer donné leur investissement
total sur le terrain d'auxerre en projet
de jeu global basé sur tous les joueurs
l'histoire de la dea blot a pourtant cru
elle était 2018
blois remporte le championnat de pro b
mais la montée est refusé pour un centre
de formation hn homologué
printemps 2020 en tête du classement
avant l'interruption de la saison avec
la crise l'as des as ne monte encore pas
s'il ya bien un club en france dont le
terme résilience résonne fort c'est bien
pour la dea blois ses cicatrices
elles font partie de l'histoire du club
peut être même qu'elle rende son
histoire différente des autres comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure et etc est là et
qu'elle augmente son capital sans
papiers et que peut-être le futur
monstre à cocumont
en attendant le présent est à la hauteur
des ambitions
le centre de formation avec 20 joueurs
apprentis et reconnue désormais dans le
paysage du basket français et un centre
de performance a été lancée à blois
tout est mis en oeuvre pour faire
grandir le club et ce malgré l'adversité